Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
When using cryptography, we'd like to safely
communicate over the internet in the presence
of third parties.
To be able to do this, and many other important
applications, we need random numbers.
But what does it exactly mean that something
is random? Randomness is the lack of any patterns
and predictability.
People usually use coinflips as random events.
But is a coinflip really random? If we had
a really smart physicist, who can model all
the forces that act upon the coin, he would
easily find out whether it's going to be heads
or tails. Strictly speaking, a coinflip is
therefore not random.
What about random numbers generated with computers?
Computers are a collection of processing units
that run programs. If one knows the program
code that generates the random numbers, they
are not random anymore, because it doesn't
happen by chance, and it is possible to predict.
John von Neumann famously said:
"Any one who considers arithmetical methods
of producing random digits is, of course,
in a state of sin. For, as has been pointed
out several times, there is no such thing
as a random number — there are only methods
to produce random numbers, and a strict arithmetic
procedure of course is not such a method."
Some websites offer high quality random numbers
that are generated from atmospheric noise.
Practically speaking, this, of course, sounds
adequate enough! If someone wants to break
the encryption of our communications, they
would have to be able to model the physics
and initial conditions of every single thunderbolt,
which means processing millions of discharges
per day. This is practically impossible.
So it seems reasonable to say that random
events are considered random because of our
ignorance, not because they are, strictly
speaking, unpredictable. You just need to
be smart enough, and the notion of randomness
fades away in the light of your intelligence.
Or so it seemed for physicists for a long
time.
Imagine if someone who has never heard about
magnetism would see many magnets attracting
each other and some added magnet powder. This
person would most definitely say it's magic
happening.
However, if you know about magnetism, you
know that things don't happen randomly, there
are very simple laws that can predict all
this movement.
In this case, magnetic forces we can loosely
call a hidden variable. So we have a phenomenon
that we cannot predict, and we're keen to
say it's random. In reality, it is not, there
is just a hidden variable that we don't know
of, that is responsible for this behavior.
We have the very same phenomenon if we look
inside of an atom. Quantum-level effects happen
according to the physics of extremely small
things, and we again, find behaviors that
seem completely random. We know some of the
trends, just like we know which roads in our
city are expected to have a huge traffic jam
every morning, but we cannot predict where
every single individual car is heading. We
have it the same way with extremely small particles.
We're keen to say
that a behavior seems completely random, because
nothing that we know or measure would explain
it. Other people will immediately say, wait
- you don't know everything, maybe these quantum
effects are not random, as there may be hidden
things, hidden variables that you don't know
of, which make up for the behavior.
We can't just say this or that is random - it
is much, much more likely that our knowledge
is insufficient to predict what is happening,
as electromagnetic forces seemed magical to
scientists a few hundred years ago.
So is quantum mechanics completely random,
or does it only seem random?
It is probably one of the most difficult questions
ever asked. How can you find out that something
you measure that seems random, is really completely
random, and not just the act of forces that
you don't know of?
And hold on to your chair, because this is
going to blow your mind. A simple and intuitive
statement of Bell's theorem states that.
"No physical theory of local hidden variables
can ever reproduce all of the predictions
of quantum mechanics."
This means that he proved that the behavior
scientists experience in quantum mechanics
are really random, they cannot be explained
by any theory you could possibly make up.
Simple one or complicated, doesn't matter.
This discovery is absolutely insane.
You can definitely prove that a crappy theory
someone quickly made up doesn't explain a
behavior, but how can you prove that it is
completely impossible to build such a theory
that does? No matter how hard you try, how
smart you are, you can't do it.
This is such a mind-bogglingly awesome theorem.
And please note that we definitely lose out
on some details and generality because of
the fact that we use intuitive words to discuss
these results, as opposed to the original
derivation with covariances between measurements.
On our imaginary list of
the wonders of the world, monuments created
not by the hands, but the minds of humans,
this should definitely be among the best them.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!